we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P you're welcome to call
anytime our anti-vaccine friend I guess
uh Eric from Mass called in and he
really assails my character in a
horrible way claiming that I'm happy
that diamond died take a listen
hey David it's Eric from math you must
be excited diamond the diamond silk died
for all your political opponents to die
from Colvin I have never rooted for
anyone to die of covet
um Trump should be arrested just because
people have different thoughts than you
do I have never ever said Trump should
be arrested for any reason other than it
appears he committed crimes
it's unbelievable I mean I don't know
where you get off on this I'd like you
to do one thing do a video on
any crime that Trump committed
but you can't because you can't find one
so he didn't do anything
but you must be a happy day for you
buddy we have done extensive videos on
that we talk and again the the framing a
crime that Trump committed
people are innocent until proven guilty
so if I went on the air and said Trump
should be convicted of x-crime people
would rightly write to me and say well
but David you're innocent until they're
proven guilty he's got to be charged
then then you need a trial but of course
there is significant evidence that Trump
was criminally uh involved in the
incitement of the riots and that Trump's
actions trying to overturn the results
in Georgia even though Joe Biden won so
that those votes would be those
electoral votes would be given to Trump
was also an extortive fraud
um it is not up to me to determine that
though it is up for uh it is up to the
judicial system and we will hopefully
soon learn more about that we've got a
great bonus show for you today Katie
Porter is running for Senate I think
she's great we're going to talk about it
number two
John Bolton now says he will run in 2024
if it's what's necessary to prevent
Donald Trump from being president again
interesting guy that Bolton not a huge
fan of his I have to tell you and
Americans are piling up credit card debt
at record rates and it could prove very
costly to the economy as well as to
people's personal finances we will talk
about all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad in addition to that
tonight at 6 PM Eastern 3 P.M Pacific we
will have our first David Pacman show
Town Hall of 2023. I really want you to
be there we will be streaming it live on
YouTube twitch and Facebook we will also
be welcoming your calls you I'm it's
really you
at davidpackman.com Discord Discord is
how we take the calls I look forward to
speaking with you you can also just
watch even if you don't have a question
for me but it's going to be great and we
will see you then otherwise back here
tomorrow